Hi, I'm Jill Wilfing, training chair of Algonquin District and the South Council, South Bend, Indiana.
This is the Scoutmaster Podcast, sponsored by Backers Like Me.
And now it's the old Scoutmaster.
Listener, Steven Cerulli, tells me that up in Ely, Minnesota,
now right there in the Boundary Waters canoe area, you can get something called Canoeber.
It's an Uber canoe, not a really big canoe, but kind of like a canoe taxi.
There's an app and everything and it covers all of the Boundary Waters.
The next thing, I guess, is self-paddling canoes.
I might be interested in that actually.
Hey, this is podcast number 344..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green, and, oh, I think we can move without any hesitation at all directly to the mailbag
Where we heard from Bill McFarlane. and Bill, you've got to go back some episodes,
but I believe I mentioned some time ago that Bill undertook to carve. are you ready to geek out?
Really? I mean, this is total Scout geek-out time,
All right. so prepare,
Put your junior Birdman goggles on folks, because Bill undertook a commitment to carve every Whittlin' Jim neckerchief slide.
And you say: who is Whittlin' Jim?
There was a feature in Boys Life magazines for many years called Whittlin' Jim.
He always had like a new neckerchief slide that you could make or carve or something,
And Bill just got it into his head. This is what he was going to do.
I'll have a link in this week's podcast now so you can go over and visit his website with pictures of all the neckerchief slides he's carved-
And it's an amazing number of neckerchief slides
I think he might be. I think he worked his way all the way through and it's channeling whittlin'jimcom.
So, Bill, congratulations if you finished and keep on going if you haven't.
Thanks for getting in touch.
Frank responded to last week's podcast.
We talked about advancement mostly last week.
He said: spot on answers on this week's podcast.
Well, thank you, Frank.
Always good to hear a good word.
Dave got in touch with a question in the comment section for last week's podcast.
He said what can be required for the show- leadership requirement for an Eagle Palm, which is a question I had not really heard before.
So I had to go check out the requirement and it says: make a satisfactory effort to develop and demonstrate leadership ability.
And I did a little noodle around.
I checked in the guide to advancement and everything.
I didn't see any specific policies or procedures or limitations involved on that requirement
And, as I recall, when I've had scouts that have earned palms, we just discussed what they had done in their effort to develop and demonstrate leadership ability
And really it was never really a big question with those guys because there they were, you know, working away at whatever. they were working at it within the troop, whether they had a specific role or not at the time.
So I can imagine any number of different ways this requirement could be fulfilled in and out of scouting, because there's nothing that says that that development has to be done exclusively as a part of the scouting experience.
We definitely want our scouts, especially our Eagle Scouts, out there spreading the knowledge and using the skills that they've obtained in scouting.
So if you've got a different take on that, I'd love to hear about it.
Or if you've ever seen any verbiage- official verbiage- about that requirement- it was a new question to me. How about that? huh
Hey, every Tuesday morning- just about every Tuesday morning- I should qualify that-
We have a live chat right around 8am Eastern Standard Time.
You go over to scoutmastercgcom, click the little chat button down at the bottom right hand of the page, sign in and join us.
Also, keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed,
And thanks to Barry Dickinson, who's the Scoutmaster Troop 175 in Foster City, California, who joined us, along with many of our frequent flyers who check in just about every single week.
We talk about serious things and not so serious things,
So stop in and join the live chat Tuesday morning.
Hey, I want to pause here to thank all the folks who are Scoutmastercgcom backers, especially Jim Smith and Rob List, who added their names to the list of backers since last week's podcast.
There's a couple of different ways to help us out to keep all this freely available to our fellow Scouters.
You can find out by going to scoutmastercgcom- look at the upper right menu on any page
And there are some support links there.
You can become a backer, which is kind of a one-time payment model,
And you can become a subscriber through Patreon, which is a monthly subscription deal.
No matter what you do, we sure appreciate your help keeping all this running.
So check those options out this week
And if you decide to become a backer or a patron, I'll make sure to thank you personally on next week's podcast,
And speaking of this week's podcast, I've got some questions to answer that you've emailed in to me
And a lot of it has to do with the Patrol Leaders Council, with the Patrol Method and Youth Leadership, which is not out of the ordinary.
But I'm anxious for you to hear these answers.
So let's get started, shall we
Adventure? that's scouting.
I want to jump up and scream and shout it.
I'm looking forward to my uniform
Because, baby, I was born to be a scout,
Because, baby, I was born to be a.
Here comes the scoutmaster
Driver. jump the scout, we'll be a little faster.
Stick on the gas. are we there yet?
I want to build a bridge for my Eagle Project.
Find me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Paul Geisler got in touch with me and asked this question:
What does the Patrol Leaders Council do when, on an outing, a majority of the patrol members of a particular patrol cannot attend due to a conflict in their schedules?
Does the Patrol Leaders Council create hybrid patrols?
I've heard of troops doing this, but it seems to me to be kind of going against the grain of the Patrol Method.
You've talked in the past about larger patrols.
This could help patrols have critical mass on a camping trip.
Well, Paul, you know you've landed on one of those nagging questions about patrols that I haven't come up with a thoroughly foolproof answer for yet.
My thinking is: patrol on a camping trip needs critical mass,
And I kind of feel like that's five guys.
It can happen with a little less, but the minimum seems to be, from my experience, around five guys,
And of course that's all dependent on who those guys are and where they're at and everything.
But just as a very general rule of thumb, that's where it seems to really be clicking along. when there's five to eight guys in a patrol on a camping trip,
That's the ideal critical mass, and things are hardly ever ideal, are they?
At least not in my experience.
Making provisional patrols when needed is one answer
I've never found completely satisfactory, but sometimes I'm stumped on what to do otherwise.
I've seen patrols of three and even two. you know they function fine, but it just isn't really checking all the boxes of the kind of interactions and things you want to see in a patrol.
Now, one way that seems to be promising that I'm going to talk about in another answer is the way that we've been doing our permission slips per quarter rather than trying to do them every month.
I'm going to talk about that in a minute in the answer to another email question.
But you know, one thing I've been trying to study these past few years is what adjustments we have to make to our application of the patrol method to adapt to the reality of our Scouts lives.
The idea of the patrol is still absolutely relevant, but many of the assumptions on which it was originally based don't exist anymore.
One assumption was that patrol would reflect kind of that natural neighborhood gang of the boys involved. but that neighborhood gang hasn't really been a factor for you know a long time,
Because school districts are 10 times larger than they were in 1910, Scouts may be best friends with somebody who's 20 minutes driving distance away or more,
And so those natural neighborhood connections, I think they're still very real in some places but in a lot of places they aren't.
The patrol method was also built on the idea of friendly competition
And I think now our Scouts value tolerance and cooperation over competition.
I also think our Scouts have a much wider group of people they consider friends and fewer that they are willing to kind of sharply compete with.
If I think about my life at Scout age- you know almost 40 years ago- and the circle of people that I considered my people, you know, my friends.
That was a relatively small group. in comparison to what I seem to see in my Scouts today.
They just seem to have a much broader group and they're not quite as tribal as I think that I was. when I was growing up-
And I think I've mentioned this before- one of my youth leaders and I were talking about this once and his reflection was: it's a little difficult with these guys because they don't want to be broken up into little groups.
They like being in a big group.
Like I said, I'm still working on ideas about this.
I have a promising. what I'm going to share with you in a moment,
And I think what I encourage everybody to do as well as you, Paul, is to sit down with your youth leaders and discuss this,
Listen carefully and see how they understand the way patrols work.
Are patrols just logistical divisions for administrative purposes, or are they something more?
What benefit do they see rising out of patrols and what problems do they see?
What would they like to change?
What would they like to strengthen?
I would be really interested to hear what they have to say about that
And then, you know, start a process of working towards addressing some of those concerns and meeting some of the goals that they express.
Now listen, I don't think this is anything new or unprecedented in Scouting.
I think things started changing as soon as the ink was dry on the signatures. that started the whole thing in 1910.
And that it's been a challenge for Scouters and for organizations to keep up with what goes on ever since then.
And we find good methods and we find good ways of making this work.
But I think the understanding has to be: we can't base what we're doing today on the conditions that existed decades ago.
And for us old guys, you know that's a big step to make.
We have to actually inquire over what we're trying to achieve and how we're best going to achieve it, rather than whether or not we're going to preserve some kind of tradition or a habit of some kind.
Because, yeah, I know, you know we're always more comfortable with doing things the way that they've always been done.
But when we run into problems and we don't see results, that's when we should start asking questions, isn't it?
This next email question? the sender asked to remain anonymous and said this:
How do you keep your older Scouts interested in Scouting if you're at a point where your older Scouts are losing interest or have lost it entirely and just seem to want to punch their eagle card.
Do you have a big serious meeting with them, or would that just turn them off even further?
We're really trying to get our youth leadership motivated, but they're used to Scouts without that and they really don't know what to do.
It's like kind of like we gave them the keys and we told them to drive, but they couldn't even make it out of the parking lot because they have no idea how a car works.
I know just taking the wheel from them isn't the way, nor is backseat driving.
So where do you start when you need to pretty much start at square one?
Well, this is not an uncommon question.
So you're a Scouter and the light kind of comes on and you say, oh, we should really have youth leadership taking care of a lot of stuff that we're taking care of now.
We should really get the patrol method rolling and everything like that,
And you're dedicated and you are definitely focused on making this happen and you're ready.
And then you go and you try a couple of things and the Scouts look at it like a dog with a new pan and they go: what's this.
You know we don't know how to do this.
Well, imagine I'm coming over to your house and I'm going to say that the rules now say no more cooking in the kitchen.
We're going to move the stove into the living room.
We'll run a garden hose through the window, set a wash tub on the sofa-
It'll be fine-
And we're going to fill the kitchen sink with daisies.
We're all going to move the fridge into the attic, because every good family has a fridge in the attic.
You got to go up and down the stairs a few times, but you'll get used to it.
I mean, is that going to? are you going to be happy about that?
Of course not.
You know it's. I'm just totally upset in every apple cart that you've got apples in, if you have an apple cart.
So what I'm saying is is that that is the way Scouts are going to look on this.
If they've been around for four or five years or three or four years and they're used to the things happening one way
and you decide you're going to change it all of a sudden,
they're going to react the same way that I would. that you would react if I came up to your house and put your kitchen, in the living room.
You understand what needs to be done,
You understand what you want to see. but they have no idea.
And if you just roll in with a whole bunch of changes all at once,
you know that's not going to work real well
And it's going to frustrate your Scouts. and it's going to frustrate you because you think,
oh, they'll get this right away, because it's so much better,
It's going to be great,
They're pretty fast on the uptake. but you can't just roll in with a whole bunch of changes all at once
and expect them to understand or to get excited about all those changes.
I mean, you mentioned that they just want to. in your perception,
they just want to hang out and punch their evil card.
Well, that's because that's what the last group of older Scouts probably did, and likely the group before that.
That's all they have to go on.
And it's important that you don't blame them and you don't cop an attitude.
They're only doing what they know.
So moving a troop into a youth led model can't be just tossing all the older Scouts into the deep end of the pool.
You've got to take them by the hand and kind of wade in slowly from the shallow end
Small steps supported with lots of encouragement, success in small things that you build on
happy Scouts, and that's an indication that you're traveling at the right speed.
When stuff doesn't take hold and when things kind of fall apart a little bit,
well, that's an indication maybe they aren't getting the message
and you aren't doing a very good job of getting the message across
and you're probably trying to move too fast.
So my best advice is: set these guys up to succeed.
Help them, take them by the hand, walk them through the whole process a few times
and understand. some of them may not want to do it and may not get it,
and they don't want to see things changed.
The other thing to do is to work with the other volunteers involved, with the troop,
and decide what's an adult responsibility and a scout responsibility.
Planning is a really tiny slice of what happens. Planning is easy.
Don't put too high a premium on planning or the origination of ideas.
If you throw a calendar down on the table and you tell the Scouts to plan something,
they're going to be befuddled.
Emphasize preparation and execution of the plan.
Get them more involved in that.
Look at what adults are doing now and what you'd like to see Scouts doing
and go in steps to make that happen.
And the final bit of advice about this is: you cannot compare
the way that they're going to perform as youth leaders
to the way that adults perform when they were doing all of that work.
Reset your expectations of success and failure.
Lower the bar a bit- because these are young people
very often making their first forays into this idea
of a real responsibility and leadership for something like this-
And make sure that your level of expectation is keyed in
to the idea of them succeeding in very small things at first,
and then you build on it,
Congratulate them for doing a great job,
Bump up the expectation a little bit and repeat.
When you're in a situation like this, where the adults
have been doing everything and you really want to see
the youth leaders take over, it isn't simply passing the baton
or throwing a switch.
There's a transitional period for the Scouts and the adults
to begin to learn a new set of expectations and skills,
And if they're failing to do so, it's not indicative
of a lack of interest or talent or initiative on their part.
It's more likely you're not giving them enough time
to understand what's going on.
Maybe you're not giving them enough support
and you might be moving a little bit too fast.
I had this email from Timo Sopeta,
who's the Scoutmaster of Troop 343 in Selma, Texas.
You mentioned in a recent podcast a quarterly program model.
I'm extremely interested in what this means.
It sounds like something that we need in our troop.
Well, I have been kind of nibbling around the edges of this
and I'm prepared to talk about it a little bit more.
I've been hesitant to because we just started doing this last fall,
So we've only been through a couple of evolutions with it.
But let me explain what I'm talking about.
The quarterly plan idea is really very simple.
So what we did is we took the year and divided it into quarters,
very closely aligned with the quarters that the school district has.
So our first quarter, I think, begins in September.
So we go September, October, November, then December, January,
February, then March, April, May, then June, July, August-
Those four quarters.
So 30 days in advance of each quarter
we have a parents meeting in a court of honor,
which is a good thing to do every quarter anyway.
What we do at that meeting is we hand out the permission slip
for the next quarter,
And the permission slip has all the details
for the next three camping trips.
And when I say all the details, I'm telling a bit of,
I'm telling a little bit of a fib.
Okay,
It has the dates for the next three camping trips,
the target, that activity that we have planned, and the place,
Because, to be completely honest with you,
we haven't had every single detail for those trips ironed out
three months ahead of time. but we do have dates.
So we hand that permission slip out with all those details on it
And at that meeting 30 days ahead of the beginning
of the next quarter,
And then we ask for those permission slips to be returned
to us within two weeks time.
The idea is that 100% of the families will return those
permission slips to us telling us what camping trips
they are making a commitment for and which ones
they will not be attending.
The idea is 100% within two weeks.
We haven't actually hit that.
We've gotten like 80 or 85%, which is real good,
but we're only about three evolutions into this
And you know we're learning along the way that we have
to do an awful lot of work to get those permission slips
back within two weeks time.
So, once we have the commitments,
we're still two weeks in front of the beginning
of the quarter
And that means we're anywhere from four to six weeks
out for the first camping trip in that quarter.
Once we have those commitments, we take that to the patrol
leaders council and we discuss whether or not any
changes need to be made to the way that patrols are
set up. at present,
For instance, there may be one patrol with only two guys
on one of the camping trips and three guys
going on the other two
And we say maybe we should shuffle patrols around
a little bit for this quarter so that we have more guys
in patrols going on camping trips and making
preparations and things like that.
So far I don't think we've made any major changes
to the way patrols are.
But you understand what the point is, and this references
an earlier email answer in this podcast.
What do you do when you have two or three guys
from a patrol going on a camping trip?
The only real way that I've been able to fix that
so far is to totally avoid it by asking everybody
way up front what their commitments are
for those three months.
And, like I said, it hasn't caused us to make a whole
lot of adjustments
This most recent quarter. we really kind of fell down
on the job of getting all the commitments back
on time, so we weren't able to go through this
process.
It's a little bit of a mess,
But hey, a little bit of a mess is better than a
total mess.
So you know, we're soldiering on with it.
The other thing we do is we look at that roster
of commitments and we ask the patrol leaders
council if we need to have patrol leader
elections and we talk about who's going to
occupy those leadership roles for the coming
quarter.
For many years our senior patrol leader was
elected on an annual basis,
Seemed to work,
And then we decided that we would cut that down
to six months at a time, and that worked fine.
And part of the implementation of this
quarterly program was that we would elect a new
senior patrol leader every three months.
Now that's going to make some people's head
explode,
But one of the things that we're trying to
address is the way that electing a senior
patrol leader who had the best of intentions
and really wanted to do the job and was a
great pick, but whose schedule prevented them
from going on 50% of the camping trips for
the time that they were senior patrol leader,
It just didn't. it didn't seem satisfactory for
everybody involved.
So now we have this rule of thumb,
It would be a good idea to elect a senior
patrol leader who's going to be on the next
three camping trips and who's going to be
available to make all the troop meetings for
the next three months.
And this perhaps has been one of the better
outcomes of this system, because last fall,
in the way that things go, I had four or
five older scouts who would normally be
considered as potential senior patrol
leaders, were participating in the marching
band,
And if you know anything about marching
band, at least around here, was like a
very time intensive commitment where they
couldn't make troop meetings and they
weren't going to be on any outings because
on Saturdays they were off in a parade
or at a football game.
On Monday nights- our troop meeting
nights- they had rehearsals, and if we
had done what we normally do and just
elected a senior patrol leader for the
next six months, it probably would have
been one of the guys in the marching
band and then he would have disappeared.
And whose fault would that be?
You know? I mean, is it the senior
patrol leader's fault?
Not really, because I don't expect them
to be thinking that way, because I know
that they don't.
So the idea of asking them,
hey, are you going to be on the next
three camping trips,
Are you going to be able to make the
meetings?
And getting their parents involved in
that- because parents are a little
smarter about schedules sometimes,
Notice, I said sometimes-
It really has worked very, very well
for us.
The other thing is that we now have
twice the number of opportunities for
somebody to be the senior patrol
leader and we have a pretty deep bench
in the way that that goes. right now.
We have a lot of guys who have a
lot of good leadership potential who
can fulfill that role.
Since we implemented this,
a couple of things that have happened
that were very unlikely to
happen in the past:
100% attendance from the senior
patrol leader on every camping trip in
the past six or eight months. nearly
100% from patrol leaders. almost
100% attendance of the senior
patrol leader at troop meetings
and patrols that are at critical
mass for camping trips.
The other thing that has proven to
be very valuable with this is, if
we have commitments that far out,
we can adjust the logistics for a
trip.
No waiting until the week of the
trip to find out that there are
too few scouts attending.
And, by the way, the senior patrol
leader and patrol leaders have a
cross commitment.
They can't go.
There was backpacking trip where
we needed to arrange a bus
charter and we have to have
critical mass to be able to do
that.
Well, we knew that we had it
quite a ways out,
So that was supportable.
And finally, the other
plus is that the families
are growing to appreciate the idea
that we're doing this.
It cuts down on our administrative
burden because instead of
trying to collect a whole
bunch of paper and payments every
month, now we're doing it once every
three months.
So if parents are writing a check,
they write a check once every three
months instead of every month,
And it's made life a
lot simpler that way.
So that's kind of
an overview of the quarterly
plan.
We made a commitment to follow it
through for a year
and to assess it at the end of
the year and see if it was
something we wanted to continue
with,
And thus far I believe that it's
working really well and I hope
to see it continue.
One last email from Kevin
Ames who asked this
question.
I'm the scout master of a new
scout trip, but I've been a
scouter for a while now.
I've found a lot of
information on the positions of
responsibility. with the exception
of junior assistant scout master,
I haven't been able to find a
whole lot of information, ideas
how this position can best be
used.
I presently have an Eagle
Scout who wants to remain
active with the troop in this
position, but I'm unsure how
it's going to work.
Give me some ideas on how I
should treat this role of
responsibility.
Well, Kevin, that's an
excellent question
And it's one that actually
I'm not going to try and
answer on the podcast.
I'm going to answer in a
blog post that should be
up within a day or two of
the podcast publishing.
So keep your eyes open and
watch scoutmastercgcom for a
post titled What is a
junior assistant scout master?
It's been something I've been
working on in my troop during
the past several months.
I have some exciting stuff to
share about that,
So check that post out a
little bit later on this
week.
Once again, it's titled
What is a junior
assistant scout master.
Hey, if you have a question
or comment, I would love to
hear from you.
It's easy to get in touch
and I'm going to tell you
how to make that happen in
just a moment.
Music
Well, thank you so much for
listening to this 344th
edition of the scout master
podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
to keep in touch, You will find 1,600 articles and all of the past editions of the podcast
at scoutmastercgcom. You can subscribe to receive updates to the podcast and the blog
by email. You can join us in the vast panorama of social media outlets. Join all the folks
who like Scoutmaster Blog on Facebook. You can watch us on YouTube and pin us on Pinterest
and tweet with us on Twitter, but if you're just an old crabby person who doesn't
like any of that stuff, that's okay, Bunky, You can just swing right into the late
1990s and fire off a good old-fashioned email. I'm always available at Clark at
scoutmastercgcom. That's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom. If all else fails, the
next time you're out camping, gather your fellow Scouters around a magic mirror,
say Scoutmaster CG three times in unison and I will appear to answer all your
questions. Give it a try. It really happens. You have to have the right magic
mirror, though. Well, by now it should be abundantly clear that the Scoutmaster
Blog and the Scoutmaster Podcast are not official publications of anyone in
particular other than myself. No, I am not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America or any other scouting organization for that matter. I have
just stumbled on a way to make a podcast, put it online and people for some
reason listen to it, and it's become my way of lending a hand to my fellow
Scouters and having a little bit of fun. and speaking of fun, here he is our
founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good
camping, Why? thank you, sir. Until next time, everyone.